في المسجد الذي كان متحفا اختتم الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حملته الانتخابيه
صلاه العشاء في ايه صوفيا وسطه هتافات
المصلين من مؤيديه مشهد حمل رمزيه لتوجه
رئيس حزب العداله والتنميه والمرشح
الرئاسي لتحالف الجمهور في المقابل
المنافس الابرز لاردوغان كمال كليتش دور
اوغلو رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري والمرشح
الرئاسي لتحالف الامه اختتم حملته بزياره
لضريح اتاتورك مؤسس الجمهوريه التركيه
العلمانيه برفقه عشرات الشباب وهي زياره
تحمل دلالات التوجهه وطبيعه منافسته زياره
للمتنافسين الابرز قبل حلول الصمت
الانتخابي في البلاد وهي فتره تسبق
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه تمنع
فيها الدعايه الانتخابيه على كافه الاحزاب
كما يمنع قيام اي من المرشحين بنشاط
ترويجي او ما من شانه استماله الناخبين